great what is going on a Takata well the
newest development here is that ten
percent of the 4.1 million cars that
they've fixed with replace air bags they
say they're going to have to go back and
re replace them the reason for this is
these airbags have what they are now
referring to as batwing shaped inflators
those are the inflators that are
involved in the vast majority of
injuries and and involved in the deaths
that have actually killed people in
their cars when they've exploded upon
deployment and broken up pieces of metal
and plastic in the airbag and really
shot out at passengers so Takata is
going to go back and re replace the
airbags in those vehicles they're going
to do that after they fix millions of
other airbags first because one of the
the problems here is that they still
after all these years don't have a root
cause and they suspect that one of the
problems is these airbags are sort of
breaking down over time so they're going
to replace older airbags first and then
go back and re replace these airbags
well it doesn't say much does it about
how cicadas been handling these recalls
does it no it doesn't Washington really
has expressed a lot of frustration with
the company taking this piecemeal
approach you know first it was you know
addressing just airbags in in high
humidity regions refusing to admit that
there was a defect they've only recently
you know stepped back and said okay yes
we do have a defect here we're going to
do a national recall now it's a matter
of having to go back in and clean up a
mess that it is sort of recreating and
it's it's really just speaking to the
fact that this company has really
bungled this situation from the
beginning